WE HAVE BRET BAIER.
ARE YOU THERE?
>> SO MUCH BETTER.
THANKS.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT, AND WE
BEGIN WITH A POLITICAL
BLOCKBUSTER TONIGHT.
PRESIDENTIAL ATTORNEY RUDY
GIULIANI'S AS SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLER IS PROMISING TO
FOLLOW JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
GUIDANCE THAT A SITTING
PRESIDENT CANNOT BE INDICTED.
THIS OBVIOUSLY HAS IMPLICATIONS
FOR THE RUSSIA COLLUSION PROBE
AND MAY COME AS A SEISMIC
DISAPPOINTMENT TO SOME OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CRITICS.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS TELLS US MORE FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE NORTH LAWN.
>> I SPOKE WITH HIM ON THE
TELEPHONE IN THE LAST HOUR AND
HE CONFIRMED TO FOX NEWS THAT
ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER ASSURED
THE PRESIDENT'S OUTSIDE LEGAL
TEAM THAT HE WOULD FOLLOW THE
DOJ GUIDELINES THAT THE SITTING
PRESIDENT CANNOT BE INDICTED.
GIULIANI SAYS THAT MOLAR DOESN'T
HAVE ANY CHOICE, HE HAS TO
FOLLOW THE FINDINGS OF A 1999
CLINTON ERA DOJ MEMO.
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT TEETH OR
STOMACH MUELLER COULDN'T FIND
SOME EVIDENCE OF WRONGDOING, BUT